you were the first director that
michaelbay actually handed over the
reins to which is a big deal so whose
was there any passing of the torch
conversation and then how was it working
with him as a producer working with Mike
was great we sat down early on and had
multiple conversations and it was a real
thrill for me you know
director door director to sit down with
somebody and pick their brain in their
process and the way they approached
story the way they approached character
the way that persimmon cinematography
and visual effects because he's been the
shepherd of the Transformers franchise
for the last decade you know he really
knows these characters and it was
important for me to understand how all
that worked from his perspective now of
course I knew that I was going to do my
own thing but it was really important
for me to understand what his priorities
were as a producer I couldn't have asked
for a better partner there because he
knew that this was going to be a
different kind of a story and he knew
that this was going to be my film and I
think that as a director himself he
knows what what a director needs what
kind of support he needs from the
producer and he and he basically said
with hey this is your film I'm gonna
support you and I'm gonna protect the
movie as much as I can and that's
exactly what he did and that's that's
you know that's a dream for a director
you could feel that collaboration and
watching it how it is your thing but it
also respects the franchise as a whole
which I appreciate well I'm a fan I'm a
fan of the films I'm a fan of the
cartoon and I wanted to make sure that
this film had a foot in each world and
and and and really did respect you know
what the fans love about this franchise
because that's what I am
are there any stop-motion filmmaking
techniques that came in handy here I
think so I mean I think it came down to
you know a lot of that I use every
single trick at my disposal in this
movie and then something I learned a
bunch of new ones too but part of it
came down to the to the way we approach
visual effects and you know we wanted to
try to capture as much stuff in camera
as possible possible which is what we
always do in some motion but then just
the physicality the tactility that you
know I generally that I bring to the
stop-motion table
I wanted the CG to feel like that I
wanted to feel real I wanted to feel
like you could touch it and I wanted the
emotion to be real and so weaving all
those things together with this great
team at ILM I think we
got something pretty special speaking of
those new techniques anything you're
gonna take back to Leica with you I
can't even begin to say it's a whole new
bag of tricks and that's one of the
things that I was most excited about in
this process is I knew I was gonna learn
something new I knew I was gonna do
something I've never done before and I
was gonna come out at the experience
that I with a whole new host of
processes and tools and relationships
and experiences that I was gonna be able
to apply to what I do down the road so I
think it's it's gonna be exciting to
bring those new tools into play and how
about something that could be somewhat
familiar like directing an actor in a
sound booth does do you have to use
different techniques on this because
it's not stop motion and it's something
different it's I mean it's largely the
same it's a little bit different you
know oftentimes in when you're directing
actors and in a sound booth they don't
have their the partner in the scene in
with them in the room and so you have to
play the scene in a number of different
ways because you never know what the
other person is going to do and you
craft that performance in the in in
editorial so there was there was an
aspect of that to a degree in this film
because because Haley is her co-star
isn't there either bump her but most of
the film she's acting against thin air
and so a lot of those same those same
tools you bring to play but yeah I mean
you got to be nimble the urgency the
speed of a on a line that consent is so
much quicker than in an animated film
and you have to give in to that kind of
energy and it's exciting it's thrilling
when you're creating something in the
moment and particularly when you have an
actress talented as Hailee Steinfeld
when she's you know with she puts aside
all the frenzy of all the stuff that's
going on as we're trying to make our day
and she creates this kind of beautiful
subtle quiet moment I mean it's just
magic
you